whatever's happening here the other
person doesn't know and they're in
happiness so why would I insert myself
yeah that's fine but cheating and murder
are different though right the same
thing they're adjacent I think the same
thing pain and pleasure the
[__] exactly you know
[Music]
have you guys ever known anybody that
was like into kinky stuff to the point
where they liked pain a lot of Buddhism
stuff
Buddhism like meditation
Buddhism that's what it's called [__]
pain you're short enough yeah like you
ever I mean like in the early years of
dating did you ever nah like a girl ever
scratched you too hard and you're like
hey I like falling asleep and having to
[__] me while I'm sleeping
so you can Ram fully exactly well random
you've never read whatever rib cave dude
you're down to [__] with some nasal
strips on
I tell my girls suck me twice and then
hit me the third time see what happens
here's uh just based on uh the just
based on how she looks what do you think
she's into oh choking spitting cutting
killing that's piercing she's probably
into line dancing oh who are the people
in the background around Abraham Lincoln
she's trying to get Inked while she's
getting [__] that looks like Abraham
Lincoln it's hot candle wax too [__]
I'm just that's nice that's like cliche
right hot candle wax before no I never
did I never did I got really surprised
I don't like I don't want pain when I'm
doing sexy sexy yeah I don't think I
wonder where that comes from
I've been abused I don't want a little
oh you like pain no I don't know where
it comes from because that's what I said
the pain and pleasure nerves are like
right here maybe for ladies let me ask
you this though do you guys like choking
a little bit though I think that's
general practice like choking or being
choked I don't like being choked but I
don't mind
I think most girls like that
choke me a little bit I just go like
this
hey baby hey babe you ready for this
[Laughter]
that's the wall like like the [__]
AMC Vines
my favorite is like this from the back
oh yeah yeah whoa that's some team
Kennedy yeah dude that's what he did to
me
that woman she's a 27 year old UK woman
who is into something called knife play
oh no
like Shane while she's [__] I think
it's tic-tac-toe on the skin is it like
this like cold steel yeah so her and her
boyfriend both enjoy knife play oh no so
are they a part of the renaissance fair
and then they go like this hi
slits that they're
bleeding and then they scar up yeah it's
probably like little like little
bloodletting and oh my little Cuts here
and there oh that's a really interesting
okay if they're both into it I mean it's
great that they found each other true
they are except one of them died killed
somebody it kind of peaked because then
uh at some point it's peaked at some
point she makes a call a video call to
her friend
and goes like this and shows her and her
boyfriend and she goes
I've done it and her boyfriend is
stabbed 22 times dead oh I've done it
and she giggles oh and that's how she
got caught because her friend reported
it of course she is screen recorded huh
her friend's a little stitched though
huh
that's like the biggest offense of all
yeah whoa whoa whoa hold on no rats in
this room no no but again that goes back
to the 80 and the bedding though if she
doesn't say anything she's [__] now
because her friend you're a snitch
though because you're defending her
I am defending
about a second I'm defending her yeah
let's say this so yeah let's talk so so
Ryan he stabs up his lady right okay
yeah right and he calls you he's like
dude I did it you're gonna call the cops
on [__] right if he you would do that
who's the chick smack you go like this
oh right you what you farted okay
here's the thing though I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go I think the reception's messed
up
Ryan has also killed so many people yeah
that I if I saw him call me I'm just
like that
that's yeah you have to do the basically
the legal version of like when your home
is kissing somebody you do this yeah
yeah I have this I had to say something
oh this is the reception otherwise like
you like for real aided a question
though this is an interesting thing dude
and I had to think about this because I
wondered if like if I caught like let's
say
I knew
I don't know if I could ever snitch on
somebody if I knew they were cheating on
somebody else because I feel like I
would be breaking up a happy
relationship which which relationship
the cheated so let's say like all the
dirt coming out like what they have
going on is Happy exactly I don't know
like I'm so scared to ruin this oh yeah
right because whatever's happening here
the other person doesn't know and
they're in happiness so why would I
insert myself yeah that's fine but the
cheating and murder are different though
right the same thing they're adjacent I
think the same thing pain and pleasure
than [__] exactly you know I
don't really know if she's into kinky
knife play I think that's an alibi
oops got a little horny yeah yeah yeah
one Alibis normally exonerate you from
the crime
no but then for her it's like your honor
it was an accident we were having nice
play sex that's right we should have
followed my two stabs that's all you get
back it's not so she's not saying it's
accident she's she's uh woefully
admitting that she stabbed them 22 times
in his sleep oh he was oh it wasn't even
sexual oh my God what also but she's
the life sexual [__] comes in it may
have been one way sexual whoa but not
for him wait so they haven't done that
before no they they do knife play but
they don't do stab you in your sleep
that shouldn't count as knife play okay
well that just sounds like an angry
girlfriend because you cheated on her
could be oh she didn't say though the
only thing is that she giggled and she
said I did it yeah that's [__] up
anybody who's giggling after murdering
somebody's like that that's [__] yeah
you next and if she says it that way
doesn't it sound like maybe prior they
had disgusted already yeah like this is
my fantasy and I've always wanted to
fulfill it right so she's like when she
goes like I did the you know by the way
I forgot to tell you guys she's got her
wall covered in photos of serial killers
okay okay so she's got Dahmer she's yeah
so yeah you call the cops on her and
[__] lock her ass up yeah dude and
then open shut case yeah and when the
guy gets buried you also call him an
idiot he's like you [__] dummy if you
see [__] Jeffrey Dahmer on the wall
and you're like oh maybe I should stay
[__] idiot I mean rest in peace homie
I'm sorry you passed that's kind of on
me Jeffrey Dahmer yeah
that kind of proves how guys will do
anything for [__] yeah that's true
that's like oh my God but she actually
she's so hot that [__] is so good and
then also I'm imagining the friend too
like if she was like I did it haha then
maybe she's already told the friend but
then the friends probably like oh like
you wanna you wanna kill your boyfriend
you're so crazy yeah maybe it's like you
don't think they're serious yeah like
what are you gonna really do you're not
gonna you're definitely not gonna snitch
if they just say it and they haven't
done it right so you're also going to be
like oh you're you're crazy and then it
happens it's like okay that all right I
gotta call the cops because at this
point I feel like oh she's just a
cosplay fan girl you know she likes she
likes all this [__] she's into serial
killers
if it's like cheating I'm I'm not
stitching like if it's really
uncomfortable or if it's close to home
or the chicks my a friend as well I'm
like I'm walking away from that like
that I'm not but I'm not snitching right
but and it's not even if it's murder I'm
like dude how bad of a crime does your
homie have to do to make snitching okay
I don't give a [__] it murder no murders
if I'm cheating on Hannah and you don't
snitch on me I'm gonna [__] you up
explain this logic so how does he win
ever dude this will the entire [__]
time he's always like rats are worse
anybody who's thinking snitches dead man
why why is that the case how come cause
man
[Laughter]
okay well if it's on camera then I'm
exonerated but point is we're good and
the only other time on a situation like
that is like maybe if like my homie was
maybe like dating my sister or something
like that like if it's like happening to
my blood and my family then I'm like you
[__] up like you crossed up is your
sister really attractive she's
absolutely beautiful [__] fine dude
like I was like but Steve Green sister
oh my God she's different though she's
like Pamela Anderson wait Steve says
yeah dude how old is she
I don't know
she's so hot though that Steve was like
yo I should have been on the [__]
Lannister Steve gets jealous when we're
like checking it out she's like don't
[__] check She's mine
anyways let's focus on the murder yeah
so uh Geico no guy code for this [__]
murderer though Geico well they're girls
so of course Geico doesn't count that's
why she's rat knock I don't know this
guy looked like a vampire maybe she was
just checking to see
he's like no I'm just kidding recipe
song I was like you didn't get the heart
it just really hurts what is that silver
yeah I don't know that's that's all that
happened man died in the end it was
really good looking though
[Music]